foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the journey to the
microcosmos live stream that's I was
going to say it's like a celebratory
thing it's not really tied to anything
important or fun uh we just kind of
wanted to do one of these just because
things to talk to all of you out there
who watch our show that we like to make
coincidentally though we did just hit
700 000 subscribers like a couple of
weeks ago
so we can say
this is celebrating that even though yes
that's Happy 700 000 subscribers
everyone
uh so yeah thanks everyone for tuning in
uh we have more people than we normally
do uh in these live streams and so we'll
introduce them here in a second uh but
that's just you know so you know behind
the scenes the microcosmos team is also
growing if you watch all the way to the
end of the video and see the credits you
might notice that it seems like every
week we're adding somebody new to those
credits which is great and helpful uh
and yeah so
I'll start off the the round robin here
and we can just go go around and
introduce who we are and what we do for
microcosmos uh I'm Matthew gaydos uh I
am the producer of microcosmos and yeah
I pretty much I used to be the editor
now we hired chayton who will introduce
himself but he is great and helpful and
I don't have to edit anymore
um so I'm the just the producer and the
product manager uh helping run the the
merch website over at microcosmos dot
store
uh and since I mentioned him hey Jason
uh hey everyone my name's chayton uh as
Matthew said I am the new editor on
Journey to the micro Cosmos uh so I I
cut up the stuff I put the stuff
together and then
I I do yeah I make the stuff I mean
that's a pretty good I feel like a lot
of what
we should turn it on the internet yeah
turn the clips into a video and have the
music make sense do a lot of on-screen
make sure you know how big things are
all that cut out random rests and
mess-ups make sure everything's no I
never messed up there's never been a
mistake on the show I don't know never
been a mistake one take green they call
it everything I just sent I just sent
something to Shane today in which I
cough for the majority of the record I
haven't even listen to it that is great
news
the best thing about uh editing you hang
specifically is the times you'll
randomly break into song or oh do I do
that yeah you have in the past yes you
did a full three-minute song singing
about dirt bikes yeah
I believe yeah
[Music]
um
I was waiting for the garbage truck to
go by that's the secret micro Cosmo
soundtrack yeah yeah
yeah I think there's a lot of videos I
think if you listen closely you might be
able to hear a truck rumbling in the
alley behind Hank's house yeah
um but yeah I think uh I guess touching
on the editing and like saying how you
like make stuff I do think microcosmos
it's worth noting is edited in a very
different way from a lot of not only
like other YouTube channels but also the
other things we may get complexly and so
for those that don't know uh like James
is capturing all of our footage uh
Andrew Wong makes all of our music but
he like already made that like a long
time ago and like reduced it for us and
so we have the stems and all the pieces
uh of those songs and so it really is
like a weird show to put together
because we take the narration from
anchor to boki the footage from James
and uh try to make it match up with
whatever music we want to put in that
time and
it's just it's a lot of trial and error
uh in editing microcosmos where you're
like does this song sound good no
I can't say when making the episodes I
probably go through like two or three
passes of trying to figure out what
music should go where because I'll think
I know what song I want to put
underneath uh handker to bookie's
narration and I'll put it there and I
will edit for about like three to five
minutes of the video with that music and
then I'll be like nah nah nah scrap it
delete it go back to the beginning that
was uh that was much my experience as
well uh well uh we mentioned her a few
times uh debokie would you like to
introduce yourself
yes hi I'm devoki
um and I am the writer I've been writing
for a while for the show and then also
more recently have also started hosting
some of the episodes
that's right yeah
that is what I do that is how I make the
thing thank you Hank for the
confirmation
[Laughter]
idea that I should have said something
wrong
I was checking to make sure you never
know
so you you've been writing these things
yeah I'm I'm green the fact checker for
joining the record
do you want to introduce yourself Hank
yeah I I uh I'm the I host a lot of the
episodes I very occasionally write
episodes uh but I'm mostly uh I guess I
it was my it was it was me and James
came up with it together
um so that's I feel like the majority of
my contribution was like this would be a
good idea
never heard back from Hank again
[Laughter]
yeah
it's an AI voice now they just said so
many words that they just used yeah yeah
there's enough paint green content out
there on the internet we've just
compiled the robots things for him yeah
I mean I feel like at this point we
probably could if we I know well I know
it's possible because like people have
done it to lots of YouTubers but they've
never done it to me like there's like a
a website you can use that have like
people in it you can just pick like Mark
Rober like make a mark Rober voice
terrifying but I'm not in there yet yes
yes wow
uh make like you know pickups for
bloopers way easier we just like hey I
need Hank to say this oh thank you
computer yeah yeah actually good point
uh cool uh so James uh we've talked a
lot about what you do already but do you
want to introduce yourself
uh yeah sure so I'm the guy behind the
microscope and I just record random
things and then we make episodes about
them and
um that's pretty much what I do I just
sit here uh with my two cats which
um they definitely gonna just you know
just come here to say hi and yeah I do
microscopy
I record Clips then I send them to meds
and then we
uh write an outline and the bookie takes
it over and just makes an episode
I like that right like
that's right
I like that you made that sound so
simple but it's like literally like the
channel is all footage 100 yeah like
front to back your footage and it's uh
mostly episodes are just like you have
happened you've come across some cool
things or discovered something cool and
it's like well this is our episode now
um and so it's entirely reliant on your
very cool footage
um it's really easy for me honestly
because I I love doing that it just
um just the YouTube part is a bit
hard for me I think and you guys are
taking care of it perfectly so I just
just let me do microscopy and it's gonna
be easy for me yeah
well yeah speaking of this team and
making things easier and helping out a
lot uh let's introduce the the newest
member of our team there uh Paige would
you like to introduce yourself yeah sure
hey I'm Paige I I guess if we're talking
about makers and things like this and
people recording videos I think the best
description of what I'm here to do and
I'm brand new at doing it is helping
shape those things that people like
James and chayton make uh before it gets
into the hands of Hank for example so
I'm a new editor on the content side a
script editor
um and so I work mostly at the moment
with debokies words
um and try to make sure that they're a
nice fun story for an episode
um unfortunately she hasn't given me
tons of work yet because she's been
doing this for so long
and that has also been you know involved
for so long that um you know it's all
about like poking and asking the right
questions of like okay does this make
sense does this thought lead to this
thought where do we end this sentiment
uh this this journey through the
microcosmos but um yeah they really
haven't made it too difficult for me so
we'll see if we can dial that up in the
next three months so I can handle it if
we can now I'm just learning everything
we used to learn about the micro Cosmos
and this team
it's always nice when a new person comes
on board and it's they don't go oh wow
wow why is this happening like this
I love the fact that we can we can act
like seniors you know when somebody new
comes
experts yeah yeah yes that is exactly
what we plan to do we've been doing this
correctly the whole time
um cool well yeah this is not all of the
microcosmos team there are even more of
us like I said if you check in on the
credits of the episodes you will see a
bunch of names who help out uh regularly
they are either just not here uh because
they didn't want to be as like they
didn't want to be on camera they have
meetings people are very busy uh and
also you know the
get it gets chaotic if suddenly you have
20 people on here trying to talk
um but uh we do want to answer some of
your questions we asked for them in
advance so we have a list here uh from
you know Twitter the community tab Etc
but also if you leave your questions in
the chat here below the video we'll get
to some of those as well
um one of which actually uh came in that
I think is interesting because I think
it touches on a few different like what
James and cheating both do for the
channel uh but somebody said hey just
wanted to ask do you use any color
correction software or is the microscope
really that good
uh and the answer is both
[Laughter]
um because we the the footage that comes
from James is amazing and looks great
and basically we just boost the
brightness ever so slightly usually but
we don't like change colors of anything
yeah right that's that's that's
I I remember early on being like well
why can't like you know they can do that
with uh with infrared telescope pictures
why don't we just make it whatever color
we want and James was like no
laughs
what we can we can change the colors a
bit like in a way that we can make the
background like bluish or like
um I don't know how to say it but you
know like uh heels of blue it can be
like light blue darker blue but we
cannot change the colors of the
organisms and that's how we get it from
the microscope and a lot of people are
asking this and they're like some people
are not believing that I'm saying that
these are the real colors of them you
know so it's just they are trying to
catch them different like yellow tint in
the video and then they're like oh this
is more yellower than this one and why
is that it's because
the way that I set the microscope so it
is all about the light and yeah and you
can play with it and yeah and I think
when editing just the footage that I I
mean I barely really touch it when when
uh James sends it over for the most part
I'm literally just like bumping up the
saturation a little bit bumping up the
contrast a little bit to make the
organisms pop out a little more and
besides that the only other time that it
goes into an extreme is if I need to
highlight something to like showcase a
certain portion of the screen but
besides that most of the footage is
pretty much untouched it's just very
minor tweaks to make things pop a little
more
yeah yeah I feel I feel like that
microscope that we have now that you
have now James is uh I I know that it's
not designed just to look pretty but
it's certainly the one that you get if
you want things to look really pretty
but it's not because of the microscope
so that's the issue oh and all right hit
me yeah it's it's the like it's the way
that you
you set the microscope so you have so
many you know like different things that
you different
um things that you can play around with
so it's like you have for example these
things these are like just you know if I
tweak it a bit it makes it sharper and
if I you know turn it to the other side
just a bit it makes the background
sharper but the like the foreground more
uh like out of focus so I can play with
things a lot and I think that's making
some clips you know different than the
other ones right yeah
yeah
yeah because I'm like advising a couple
of companies and they want to get the
same microscope and they want to get the
same footage and then it's like oh okay
well maybe you can help us how to make
footage with the new microscope we got
because of you and yeah yeah nice cool
yeah I've used this metaphor before in
live streams I know because we get
questions about the microscope and
microscopy a lot but the the closest
like metaphor I've thought of in working
with James and talking with James about
microscopy is that it's like a good like
getting good at guitar where like people
I think
think that they can go buy the same
microscope that James has and be like
producing the same quality of microscopy
that James is but I equate that to like
going and buying the same guitar that
Jimi Hendrix played expecting to be Jimi
Hendrix in a day and it's like well no
like James literally spends hours a day
at his microscope honing his skill uh
and has done that for a long time
and it makes all these little tweaks and
adjustments and upgrades through the
years to make sure that like we are
getting the clearest and best footage
possible and so uh yeah I think it's
it's it's hard when people say like oh
what is your microscopy setup it's like
oh God okay okay we have a lot of
different answers to this question you
know and but also anybody can do that
it's not because I'm unique or something
just because of the time that I put into
it it's like anybody can do it and yeah
but anybody can play guitar I think I
cannot but
yeah
but you could at least you could start
playing guitar and yeah maybe get great
one day so it is possible then I can
play the guitar and I can say it's not a
good guitar that's why I cannot play
because
yeah suddenly you have a 50 000 guitar
which is why let's just not that's uh
why learn a new skill
less is microscopy that's right exactly
uh
uh which you know we got some plugs to
work in by the way uh this is sort of
the first
Public Announcement that we are about to
launch our fall wave of merchandise over
at microcosmos dot store
um in a couple of weeks not right now uh
we are going to have a bunch of new
microscopy products available as well as
new merchandise as well as old
merchandise so like the Hydra shirt that
Hank is wearing the homo sapiens
sweatshirt I'm wearing the tardigrade
shirt all of that stuff will still be
available but then we're also going to
have a soon on the store we will have a
sticker pack and a coffee mug we're
going to have a we're going to be
restocking our microscopes very soon and
we're also going to have a new model of
our microscope that comes with plan
achromatic objectives
um so that one will cost a little bit
more but it'll have the better
objectives on there and if you have the
older like the original microscope you
are also going to be able to buy Plan
objectives on their own uh if you want
to upgrade your objectives so a lot of
new stuff coming to microcosmos.store in
a couple of weeks so be on the lookout
um you know I'm counting the minutes
until
um that's the one I'm most excited about
yeah the mug is very cool it uh spoiler
alerts on the side it says uh how many
tardigrades you can fit into a coffee
mug it is not that one it is less
terrified
we are not selling that there's a lot
less terrifying than jeans as mug
um but it's uh yeah we did the math to
figure out roughly you know how many
tardigrades you could squeeze into a
coffee mug it's a lot more than you
might guess yeah yeah
uh I my initial guess was somewhere in
the hundreds of thousands turns out it's
closer to like you know two billion
yeah I was off by a little bit I wonder
what the kind of consistency would be
also are you feeling it all the way to
the top because I'm it's supposed to be
really crunchy could be crunchy okay
these are dried out
okay I was I was picturing like an
Orbeez situation where it was like where
they're still pretty goopy
uh but I guess they'd need to have water
in with them in order to stay goopy it
takes up some space yeah
um just enough to fill in the cracks but
if you if you condense this mini Target
graze into like that space then the
water just gonna be like a capillary
effect so it's just gonna be there
without you adding water okay does that
make sense yes that makes sense yeah
yeah
uh how how hard would it be
to get a couple billion tired of grades
[Laughter]
I mean are you gonna count them no no I
don't want you to know how many there
are I just want to I just want I want
the cup to be fairly full and for it to
be just tardigrates
well my cup runneth over
[Laughter]
the problem is I
from right you'd need yeah you'd need to
be feeding them and have nothing else
there and then like just let exponential
growth take over something yeah yeah and
then but in a way where they're also
like not killing each other as they're
growing so you then you gotta like grow
them up but then you gotta concentrate
them down wait this tardigrants eat each
other
no like they're I mean if they're living
in the same space or they're growing
exponentially they're gonna they eat
each other as well resources
[Laughter]
in other things and there's nothing else
to eat yeah yeah Hunger Games
you don't have to be really quick with
how fast you put those two billion into
the mug if you want them living right
um but uh you know you could probably
get a bunch of dead tardigrades in a mug
sounds like a big challenge great I'm
gonna do this
how many paragraphs were in the
tardigrades that got sent to the Moon
I mean I'm guessing not that many yeah
I'd I'd say in the dozens thousands
I think it's it's like around 2000
um yeah oh okay okay
it's a good start just do that a couple
thousand more times yeah
oh no
never mind you did the math wrong see
this is the one million more times you
start doing the math the first the first
time we did the math I ended up with
like 300 000 and I was like that seems
reasonable and I sent it to James and he
sent me back math that said 2 billion
and I was like we need to talk about
life
because basically what I had done was I
took the length of a charter grade and
like Cubed it and then just like
stacking those cubes on each other right
but like that's the longest the
tardigrade is not in every direction
yeah uh and so our grids are not cubes
and then James said we should make the
like every out of it yeah well there's
also different size tardigrades like
it's going to be very different for a
baby than a for a grown fully grown
oh do they do they have a Max size do
they run out of malts eventually
no we we calculated this from based on
one species so it's like it's not we can
fit that many Target grades of every 30
great species it just just this one so I
was thinking we can maybe put in you
know Asterix and then under the under
the cup we can write it there yeah
it says about two billion yeah or take a
billion here and there who knows yeah
that's done I mean Hank is our fact
Checkers there's only there's only one
significant digit in there so I'm I'm
happy yes it says about two billion
tardigrades in this mug
um so I feel like we're covered and I
dare anyone to challenge us and showing
that they can fit more or less
tardigrades in that mug they have to
physically do it though yeah because
because when you read this um you know
third grade papers they're like this
repeating arguments in many papers it's
just saying like in a cubic meter soil
there can be like 100 000 tardigrades I
was like always thinking
much like hundred thousand in this big
soil you know
and then we did the mat for the for the
muck and it turned out two billion maybe
they are like smaller than what I
expected actually and yeah yeah they
look very big when you put them under a
tremendous amount of magnification
yeah
uh but yeah one like that we will have
that mug available soon as well as a
speaking of Charter grade so we're gonna
have a sticker pack uh that includes a
micro bumper sticker
um which is like one and a half by four
inches that says tardigrade Enthusiast
so uh I think it would be funny if
people put that on their car uh because
they just have an actual tiny micro
bumper sticker on your car I think it's
hilarious we're gonna get a tattoo of it
but I think uh we'll also have a few
other stickers in there as well based on
our other t-shirt designs and Logo stuff
uh
but yeah uh getting to some other
questions from the chat
people want to know uh I think we've
asked this before too but we've got more
people here now in your time on working
on microcosmos uh do you now have a
favorite microbe that we talk about oh
it's a good question
does anyone have an immediate thought of
like oh obviously this one uh I'm not I
I'll go with lacra Mario which because
it's like that's what that was like
really outside of my understanding of
how things work
um and uh and just very active very
I don't know charismatic uh and
dangerous
I feel it's weirdly I feel similar about
uh Birds where I I think like if you
don't spend a lot of time around Birds
right yeah it's like I don't know it's a
bird it doesn't hurt reality but then I
worked on the show animal wonders for a
while and I was like around a lot of
birds repeatedly I was like oh I I know
this bird I feel like that's like you
reveal the personalities now behind
certain uh individual species of micro
where you're just like yeah oh these
aren't just a bunch of random dots on
myself they behave very differently from
each other and look very different and
lacrimary is like the Loch Ness monster
of microbes
easier Vibes when things have like
exclusive diets where like this thing
will only eat this thing yeah that's
always fascinating to me or I'm just
like okay but like that seems like a bad
way to live
clearly it's working for you but for now
yeah
anybody else
favorite microbe yeah
I'm trying to think of just the episodes
that I've edited I think
probably some of the most interesting to
me like visually
um and this is just from the shots that
James got so it's like maybe it's not my
favorite micro but maybe it's just my
favorite footage that we've gotten from
James
um the the nematode video uh even though
uh there there are worms there were
there were a lot of shots in that uh
that video that I I really love uh and
then uh anything Bluff left from oh
goodness
yeah uh any any shots of those I I love
just because they're they're just so I
mean the just the pink stands out so
much so out of the videos I've edited
those are some of my favorites just
because of the footage uh yeah I love I
love nematodes yeah there's too many I
think
yeah I feel like my favorites are always
the ones that I always thought were
super simple and then the more we write
about them the more you're like oh it
takes a lot to be that simple or there's
like actually a lot going on so I used
to always respond my favorite were my
favorite episodes to work on used to
always be amoebas I don't think we've
done a lot of amoebas recently but we
went through a phase of talking about
worms a lot and like that really got to
me where I was like oh worms are worms
are cool like they are weird they got a
lot going for them yeah so then I kept
telling Sam for Sideshow tangents like
that I pressured him into doing a worms
episode because I was like you gotta
talk about nematodes like I don't know
what it is but they're just fascinating
yeah those tubes in tubes it's just uh
yeah it's just it's just a tube that's
just a tube goo
I think I think I'll go ahead
I think we're gonna make another warm
episode soon
okay
um because I'm I'm looking for some
specific worms with uh bacteria growing
on them so it's like Kendra forests and
they are just farming the bacteria and
they're super interesting
you know the all bacteria weigh more
than all uh people by like by like a
thousand times or something
it's just we're just we're just living
in their world man
yeah yeah
yeah
that's that's a leg up but but also
insignificant compared to just all of
them in the ocean
yeah some of them I'm okay you know
they're a little bit helpful the other
ones I'm like there's too many of you
yeah almost all of them have nothing to
do with us like they just no interest in
our bodies at all which is great
yeah that's comforting it's always nice
to be reminded that like not everyone's
thinking about you all the time that's
yeah it's just like that yeah yeah
exactly yeah but it doesn't mean it's
gonna stay like that oh no that's the
most ominous thing I've ever heard
yeah I'm into crisper these days
uh I think like if I had to pick a
favorite I'd probably gravitate towards
Hydra just because I think it's like
yeah a few uh the reasons you guys have
a very touchdown where it's like one the
footage is always really cool when we've
got a Hydra uh moving around especially
when we see them in the context of a
tardigrade like climbing on it and
you're like oh this thing that we think
of is like a big micro in relation to
other things it's like crawling on the
tiny arm of this giant thing
um we were also able to make a really
cool shirt based on them which I liked
the the fact that like
like you know who makes Hydra shirts not
a lot of people so it's such a cool
shirt people like I I wore it to uh to
like a like a very official event once
and Catherine saw me as I was leaving
the house and she was like that that one
huh and I was like yeah it looks very
cool yeah
yeah Josh Tyra we're doing this artist
series of shirts which is this one and
the tardigrade shirt is already and now
we have a diatom shirt in the works is
our next shirt uh that would be really
good early next year
um but uh yeah that's our new artist
series where we for now it's been local
Missoula artists that I know personally
because it makes it really easy to reach
out to them and say hey friend you want
to design a shirt
um but yeah uh yeah definitely I think
watching Hydro whenever those clips come
in is always uh I think very exciting
yeah I was gonna say Hydra too actually
but maybe but I was thinking so then I
was thinking about a backup I don't know
maybe I only have a memory of a goldfish
you know 30 seconds but like forums what
oh yeah any foreign yeah
just massive and you know recording
really important information about
climate and how it has changed and with
the paleontology backgrounds like we're
just so cool
like memory because I think we just
edited one
that episode was that some of that
footage like it did give me goosebumps
just because it looked really creepy uh
yeah there there was just that one where
like
and I don't know if James was you
panning the camera or what but like the
the 4M was just kind of like slowly
moving down the screen and it looked
like it was just like a spider making a
web and like just crawling along it uh
that that episode was perfect uh before
for October yeah
don't worry about for us we've had we've
had a number of like creepy episodes
come out around like Halloween time that
like was not a plan because like some of
the stuff we can't always plan what
samples James is like going to find uh
and so we just get really lucky
sometimes that I think our uh
we've had I think our maybe our most
creepy horror movie uh one which was the
the nematode eating like fungus one uh I
think that was kind of close to
Halloween I could be mistaken there but
I think like sometimes those things just
work out
uh somebody wants to know at a very base
level and this might be a question like
for multiple of us not just James but
like at a very base level for microscopy
how do I get started
uh which is you know broad uh obviously
there's like the obvious ones like have
a microscope
um but I think do you do any of you who
regularly use microscopes uh have any
helpful tips for somebody who's just
starting out yeah I mean I think you
have to have a good Pond to start with
and one one single good Pond can can
hold hold your interest for years uh you
find a lot of different things going on
like the you you just pull out samples
from different levels different areas of
the pond different levels of the dirt
different uh temperatures different
times of the year and uh it's it's
really amazing what you find and even
like one one sample like you get like
pull out the sample and then you're like
doing like one little thing at a time
pulling it out seeing if there's
anything in there
you know the the tenth one you'll be
like oh my God that one of those I saw
that on I saw that on the channel now
I'm seeing it in real life
um and uh and also like you like it you
you can like come back to a slide later
and there'll be something that you
didn't see before because like it was
hiding it needed some time to like come
out and like start to do microbe stuff
instead of just like stay very still and
be like something weird just happened
um so there's uh I I it it is you know I
think that you gotta have a notebook and
a and a pencil and you gotta have
containers and you gotta have a
microscope and you gotta have a pond you
got it like pawns ponds is the way to go
some kind of fresh water that doesn't
move a lot Suddenly It's like wow that's
that's a lot going on whereas if I
sample like the creek uh you gotta you
gotta make sure you find a part of the
creek that the microbes can like be
chill inside of
yeah and I not that I don't want to turn
this all into a plug but I did I do want
to mention that like you you listed off
containers notebook and pens and stuff
that's all stuff we're working on to
have in in the microcosmos dot store
store uh hopefully like spring of next
year we'll have a big push of like
here's some sampling stuff to help you
get out there and start sampling uh and
yeah to me uh somebody also asked how
much can a beginner expect to spend on a
microscope
uh that's a hard question I think I mean
so here's what I'll say we bought like a
little kid microscope for Oren that was
like 50 and it's a true piece of garbage
it is like actually trash
not like metaphor it needs to be in the
trash
um and we do not use it uh so yeah I
like
um I have the microcosmos microscope I
don't know exactly what it costs I think
it's it's around three hundred dollars
yeah
um
yeah
and that that thing
um and it comes with like the the
filters that came with it are so fun to
work with the you know like the both the
color uh filters I think they're called
rhinebrick filters and the ones that
just block certain light uh and went
light through in like certain ways that
does Optics stuff and I'll be honest
with you I just I just put it in at
different magnifications I try things
out I don't know what's going to work
and what's not and sometimes I'm like
well that looks exactly the same so I'll
put that one in this pile
um and sometimes it's like holy moly
like this is a totally changed my whole
life
and now I can see all kinds of stuff I
couldn't see before
so yeah it's that that to me is like
that gives you customization it gives
you like opportunities to like learn and
understand a little bit more about how
the light is actually working and uh get
you know get actually quite good at
being able to chase microbes off across
the screen the way that no one is as
good as in this room at least it's as
good as James but
um uh that's it that's that's a fun
skill to be developing as well yeah and
then to think backwards it's so that
that I've that I've done I've like that
is no longer even in my mind that it
goes backwards it's my brain has done
that neurological thing my biggest
challenge is getting that flip to work
in my brain it takes me a good five ten
minutes once I get started be like okay
I got it now and like everybody don't
distract me because this is all I can do
now this is like I know how to move
through the slide
um but yeah I think like ah the slide
goes to the other way and yeah yeah
James is like James says
[Laughter]
yeah right left
[Laughter]
um and so yeah like obviously we have
our microscope available we're
restocking that soon so like that one's
350 that can be cost prohibited to some
people I understand but I think there is
that middle ground there between like
the 50 trash microscope that uh Hank
picked up um and some other ones and
it's also the sort of like what you're
looking to do with it because like uh I
like from what I have heard from other
people talking about our microscope is
that what it can do for the price that
it is is like kind of surprising yeah uh
so uh that's always nice to hear but
also it is one of those things where not
every microscope has the same features
and you don't always know what you're
going to want or need from your
microscope until you have it in front of
you and are messing around with it so
it's really it's really very much built
to be a a microscope for ciliates
um so you know the kind of stuff that
you're going to find in ponds the kind
of stuff that we look at look at a lot
and I think that like the diversity
there is so interesting like I think
about a lot of my friends who spent a
big hunk of change on a telescope and
I'm like
there just looked at they looked at
Jupiter a couple times
and it's still Jupiter
I've got so many so many jokes on my
mind right now Jupiter's still there
yeah it's like it's not going anywhere
it's not swimming away yeah whereas you
know like like a a microscope my
microscope is is less than their
telescope Brian is who I'm thinking of
um I just think I've got a lot more
mileage out of it I've got I've seen a
lot more like there's a lot more to to
like to understand about the world
um and like there's there's it's it's
not Jupiter every time I look it's
something else
uh and that's really fun
but uh there an example of like a big
difference between two things uh is that
this this microscope shines light
through something and then you see the
light that's shined through and then
there's other microscopes that are
designed to look at things so I can't
like look at my pants in my microscope
because that's not how it's designed
like you could maybe figure something to
take them off first
there are some workarounds that you can
do yeah I I posted a few photos uh on
our Instagram and stuff of close-ups of
our socks and our t-shirts and stuff
yeah yeah you have to like get the light
coming down it's really not yeah it's
not made for that you need to get a
super bright light over your subject
essentially
but we are working on it so we're just
gonna have like a kit
never mind
he's just working on it it is not soon
okay in my mind and it's like hopefully
when whenever we can produce that yeah
that is not like happening next week
like the other like the other stuff is
coming in two weeks that thing
specifically is not coming in two weeks
okay
[Music]
um uh I did you know I just gotta get my
plugs in that's my job producer man yeah
um I want to mention the complexity oh
yeah yeah uh that was so fun to work on
is where you can go to get this uh
that's the calendar featuring a bunch of
uh very pretty images from James uh this
is I believe eight this is like the
trachea of a mealworm yeah that was a
very weird thing actually it just so I
bought these mealworms to attract some
ciliates in the samples
and then when I put 100 microscope it
looked like a scenery I think it was
beautiful yeah yeah yeah
it's very very cool and uh that is if
you go to the microcosmos dot store
you'll see on the banner like a link to
buy this but it is actually available at
complexity calendars.com so yeah boom
plugged away
you need a calendar you might as well
also help us be a YouTube channel
yeah
sneak my last plug in is that the all of
these things we were mentioning whether
it's the microscope or the calendar or
the t-shirts or our patreon page uh like
go to support the people you are seeing
on screen right now like this channel
could literally not exist without the
support of patreon and the store and all
these things
uh so anyone who's ever bought a t-shirt
or given us a few bucks on patreon or is
just watching this and telling their
friends thank you
yeah
and uh Tai show is in the chat selling
its own calendar wow
wow
wow I feel like that's like your big
brother stealing your girlfriend
no I was gonna I was gonna do the
opposite I was gonna say I work for two
complexly channels and so I've been like
trying to figure out which calendar I'm
gonna get and I landed on it this
morning I was like it has to be
microcosmos
I pulled up the website this morning and
like don't tell my eons team you know
nobody's watching but it was microcosmos
they're just really cool
there was definitely a lot of behind the
scenes banter whose calendar was the
best I think every single meeting I went
to there was just a subtle there was
always the subtle shout out of our
calendars better than the others and
then I'd go to the next meeting and for
a completely different show and they'll
be like our calendar is better than the
others
a little healthy competition going where
like we get stats I'm like how's it
doing is it selling well all right how
do we how do we catch up to this person
uh so that's yeah I think not only is it
a very cool uh thing that helps support
the channel but also we could you know
take down the eons calendar
good though it is
I'm pretty sure we also get the stats of
which one's doing the best based on what
likes we're like oh eons is in the lead
that definitely happened when I came out
yeah it's up to it's up to all you in
the chat to get us into the lead yeah
yeah go to complexity calendars.com
there's only one calendar available
there it's the microcosmos calendar uh
if it's if you see other calendars on
the website don't believe it
unless you want more than one in which
case there's more than one you can buy
into the microposmos calendars Hank
yeah one for every room of your house
guest points points are being made I'm
on I'm in the back end right now and I'm
looking to see who's bought one and uh
so so if anybody buys one I'll let you
know and I'll shout them out
this is gonna be a sad game it could be
it could be
laughs
well yeah I uh we're obviously we're we
have only got like 13 minutes left here
which is like this always flies by
whenever we do something yeah we should
try to do them more often
um I think our last one was like maybe
six months ago maybe even a year ago
um but I have a few other questions that
we can run through uh from some of the
people out there uh one that I'm curious
about is it possible to look at gases
under the microscope oh
as you can see anything well you're
always looking at gases under the
microscope if you look at it empty but
it's you can see bubbles yeah
um yeah but do you want to specifically
look at certain gases yeah that's the
question can I can I ask is there a way
for me to see a microbe fart I thought
that's what you're gonna ask
I think we recorded it
yeah okay
that's gastro tracks just you know
um
I don't know how to describe it without
being so gross but it's just yeah it's
really gross and it's yeah they
definitely fart
there we go I don't know why so do you
have like a big folder of microbe parts
that you haven't shared with us
but
[Laughter]
but I think this was like on our list
right at the beginning of this channel
yeah I thought you were yes ending me
but no you actually do have a folder of
microbe farts
um yeah okay
we also get questions in the chat that
are like do microbes have memories can
you train a Hydra to do something all
these things are a little bit more like
uh cerebral and it's like but they fart
though
[Laughter]
um also like another thing about the gas
like I try to visualize some
um some gases with electricity so I have
some footage of that as well oh cool
yeah I don't even know what that means
and it sounds cool it's like just you
see plasma and stuff under the
microscope
cool all right well we can try to work
that into an episode at some point
um somebody asked uh who looks up the
names of all the beasts we find uh oh
yes
there's a reason he's called our master
of microscopes is because he is our uh
our Fountain of Knowledge that we go to
all the time uh and he he describes
everything for us and even when we have
follow-up questions of like okay but
which which blob in this clip is the
thing for sure can you Circle it please
um he is very helpful in that uh yeah I
I I can't remember a time that I've like
gone to James with a question and he's
been like oh I don't actually know
and with the names is um sometimes
people just you know don't trust my
names and they Google it and then they
are like ah but this doesn't exist and
I'm like yes it exists it just it
doesn't exist on the internet that's the
thing nobody put that on the internet
yet
from a post-production point of view for
me and Satan that is actually a
challenge sometimes in actually making
the show is that we want to verify the
spelling of something on a label or
whatever that we'll Google it and we're
like this doesn't exist James made this
up
like he didn't make it up it's just in
one book from 1865 or something like
that where it's like yeah
yeah weird weird papers there's two
people on the website right now I'm
assuming that both of them are hanging
out here there's two people at
complexity calendars.com one's in
Illinois and one's in Minnesota I'm
watching you both
when you check out I will know
and then I will have your name but until
you check out I don't know who you are
just Where You Are I know exactly where
you are I can see your house
[Laughter]
go to complexity calendars oh somebody
just joined us from from Washington
State right in the Seattle area nice
there's more there's somebody in St
Petersburg Florida around there and
somebody in Arkansas I think that's from
listening to a weather forecast
just popping up all over the place now
oh that looks like maybe Quebec no
that's not Quebec where's that
somewhere this is failing a geography
quiz in real time
revered auction you know yeah
Alberta there's an Alberta person we
have Quebec no no Quebec all right
Hank do you have a gavel there
we just sent it to the person in
Missouri in Minnesota
maybe three calendars
three I hope at least one of them was a
microcosmos
like I can check
if you watch this the transaction
actually take place
Catherine left a note and it says hi
live stream
[Laughter]
we'll put one in front of your toilet so
when you're like at the toilet you're
like what day is it boom checked we got
you can put them in the kitchen in front
of your desk because I always I have a
calendar over there that I have to
glance at all the time during meetings
and I'll be talking to someone and I'm
like uh yeah sure next week works just
convenient
um if you get 12 of them you never have
to worry about forgetting to turn the
page yeah
and then you get all of the images on
display all year round
two calendars and we also just have one
ship off to Alberta to Travis uh so
thank you welcome to Travis very close
by here oh that person was far away in
the United Kingdom
so for people who don't know what is
happening right now
on the back end of the shopping platform
that we use for microcosmos and the
calendars and all this stuff there's
like a live Google Earth like Globe view
as things as like purchases come in and
like the globe will rotate and show you
a little pin of like hey somebody in
South Africa somebody in Norway somebody
in this interest like you get to watch
that happen like in real time and it's
uh you can you can lose some time yeah
it like makes an animation of like the
calendar flying away from Missoula uh I
think you're also to uh amber and Tyler
Amber and Georgia and Tyler and Colorado
and the one from the in London hasn't
shown up yet but I assume that it will
thank you browser history
[Laughter]
joking that James was going to be like
live talking through microbes maybe
because we couldn't get the bike show
working so it was you here watch
something and like tell us about it but
instead of Hank live telling us where
are the calendars are going yeah
you all came to watch us but now we are
watching you
yeah we're watching your live shop
um well bringing it bringing it back to
microscopy a little bit uh I did want to
ask
um I don't know who all but I haven't
answered this but I want to ask
are there any upgrades James I assume
you have multiple answers to this uh
that you would like to see in our
microscopy on the channel are there
things that we don't we're not currently
able to do in our videos yeah
like something that you wish we could do
that we can't currently do
um
like that technology can't currently do
or that like our technology can't
currently do I think yeah I would say
that one but the other one is also a
fascinating question I also think James
froze at the perfect time oh wow that's
why that's why he was being so quiet
yeah it was just for dramatic effect
he was not deep in thoughts in that
moment yeah I I thought I pictured that
as just very contemplative yeah I was
like did I add the back question
[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
there you are
can you guys hear me yeah you're back
it's ah okay sorry
um so about the microscope uh is is that
like an upgrade that I want to get for
my microscope basically so yeah
something that you wish we could do
right now in our videos that we can't
currently do either because we don't
have the technology or maybe because the
technology doesn't even exist
hmm
well it's a good question
um
I think I wanted to use some electron
microscopy and I'm thinking about
getting one but I am about to move to
the US so it would be a bit tricky to
carry a hefty thing to move
um well it's not that big it's just like
a desktop version of it but
um but also I'm not sure how useful
you know it would be uh because we would
certainly use it couple of times but you
know if I'm going to use it 10 times
is that a good investment to get a
electron microscope to your flat yeah
we've had people but with light with
light microscopy we are done with
everything so there's one objective that
I want to get
um
which would give us more resolution so
we can see more details but that's the
literally the best objective in the
world so
but it uses a different oil for
immersion so I need to be cleaning the
oil from the slide when I switch the
objective to other oil immersion
objective
which doesn't work that well for me so
that's the only reason uh we don't have
it yet well and also when you say the
best objective in the world makes me
think it's also a very expensive
objective
uh it is yeah
um confirmed it is 16k I think yeah one
objective yeah but our 63x objectivists
um 10K as well so that's it's the second
best in the world
um
well as we uh wrap up here I I was
looking at some of the chat and people
were talking still about like getting
into microscopy a bit uh and uh I think
one of the things I've been thinking
about is that there's like these stories
of people in like Victorian era like
times when like people would invite
people over to their house to like look
at their microscope because they're like
hey I got this cool toy that you want to
come over and look at it uh I would
encourage maybe people to start doing
that if you have friends with
microscopes or if you have your own
microscopes make it sort of like a cool
thing to do like you can hang out and
like be like hey wanna come over and
look at some Pond samples with me uh I
know uh there are different like
microscopical societies out there the
San Francisco microscopical Society
that's run by our friend Ariel Waldman
uh is very active in this kind of thing
where they'll do like public events
where they'll have like six microscopes
set up out in a park and everyone can
just come and hang out and look at the
microscopes and so I think that's the
best way to like if you think you might
be into it find somebody you know who
has a microscope and just hang out with
them and stick around
yeah because I think it's like one of
those things like once you try it it's
very uh it's addictive that you
you just want to keep sampling and keep
looking through things
I'm always looking for friends so
uh and before we go I want to say uh
thank you to some people who've bought
calendars Kevin who is in Plant City
Florida where my uncle lives I've got
got two calendars and also said
something love the complexity shows and
I'm glad to help support them I think
that I'm subscribed to all of them on
YouTube Daniel Wilson is in Illinois I
shouldn't have said your last name Ben
and another one
crystal is in Portland uh Heidi is a uh
in Missoula Montana and I did look up
your address and I you drive by your
house all the time
so thank you for buying a calendar so
that we know where you live
here but obviously we have to know your
address to send you a calendar we've got
to send you the thing uh Tyler in London
uh bought two separate times so bought a
calendar and then was like I need
another one and came back and got
another one thank you Tyler Amber from
Monument work and Georgia Diego in San
Diego Caleb in Minnesota uh and uh
that's back to Tyler I think that I
already thanked Travis from Alberta but
if not thank you also Alberta and I see
you one person still hanging out in
Illinois still looking at the website
nice to see you yeah you can buy
calendars after the live stream has
ended
I still appreciate it it does still
support us uh they'll be available until
they sell out
um and then you know maybe you'll make
another one next year but we gotta see
how well this one does first yeah um but
yeah thank you everyone for watching we
are at time and I assume everyone here
has I do have a meeting right now yes uh
things to do uh so we are going to let
you go uh thanks everyone for tuning in
and watching we'll try to make it not as
long until we do the next one of these
but uh yeah thank you again for watching
in our Channel and subscribing to our
Channel and uh just being a fan of what
we do caring about ourselves buying
calendars yeah well there is that too
uh cool well yeah we'll let everyone go
thank you again bye bye everybody